when you have the leaders of the black
lives movement who are now talking about
you know if we don't get our demands
we're going to burn it down some people
have been right about a lot of this
stuff and warning about it for a long
time and you probably don't get the
accolades or anything else but I want to
show you this really fascinating video
having having just told you what BLM
they BLM has staked out their position
think about the amount of money that was
given to BM from our corporations and
from our our pathetic limp wristed
liberal Progressive buffoons who kneeled
in front of black people and washed
their shoes in the summer of love as
they burned down their businesses the
millions hundreds of millions of dollars
there is every reason to believe that
some of that money was funded to Hamas
at this point they are showing you hey
we are one we are one I want show you
this fascinating video this is from
three years ago when Don Lemon was still
employed by CNN that's how long ago it
was and actor Terry Cruz who also I
would say happens to be black went on to
debate about the radicalism of black
lives matter take a look
Terry man you stepped in
it you say that you're willing you say
you're willing to die on this hill you
taken a lot of heat for this explain
what you were thinking uh and why it's
so important that you die on this
hill well again you know I want to bring
up the fact that you know there are some
very very you know militant type forces
in Black lives matter and what I was
issuing was a warning you know it's one
of those things where I've been a part
of different groups I've been a part of
different things and you see how
extremes can really get can go far and
can go wild and then when you issue a
warning and when a warning is seen as
detrimental to the movement how can you
ever ever have checks and balances um
you know in the 60s and 70s airplanes
went down all the time and the reason
they found out why they did was because
the pilots could never be questioned and
when you have the leaders of the black
lives movement who are now talking about
you know if we don't get our demands
we're going to burn it down uh other
black people who are talking about
working with other whites and other uh
other races they're they're being viewed
as sellouts or called
Uncle it starts to start you start to
understand that you are now you know
being controlled you're not being
treated as love you're actually being
controlled someone wants to control the
narrative and I viewed it as a very very
dangerous self-righteousness that was
developing that you know that that
really viewed themselves as better it
was almost a supremist move let me jum
where they
view their black lives mattered a lot
more than mine I mean isn't that
something there were people calling out
this nonsense right it wasn't it wasn't
just like the political crew of people
that could see see what was going on
here right and US hysterical YouTubers
like guys something ain't right here the
people saying that they're for tolerance
and peace are the ones blowing apart
buildings and you know destroying small
businesses and everything else did you
see by the way the the Chiron that's the
uh little piece that they put under with
the guest's name it said Terry Cruz
defends his statement of uniting with
good people black or white as if that's
a controversial statement Terry Cruz hey
black white people let's all unite
together let's fight the forces of eil
and blah blah blah blah blah but he's
kind kind of the the SC the the scary
person in the
picture